. OK, so we're back.
We have a huge week this week.
This is tonight.
Donald Trump is going to hold what will likely
be his last political rally as president in
Georgia in support of incumbent Republican
Senators Kelly Leffler and David Perdue, even
though he's been insisting that the Georgia
Senate races are rigged, he's still saying
go and vote for Kelly and David.
We're going to cover that rally live tonight.
Tomorrow are the two runoffs in Georgia tomorrow
night.
We will cover results live as they come in.
And then Wednesday, January 6th, Vice President
Mike Pence is going to preside over a formal
counting of the electoral vote in front of
a joint session of the House and the Senate.
And we have learned that some Republicans
are planning to try to steal the election
from Joe Biden, who, remember, won by quite
a bit.
This is the biggest attack that we've seen
on the fundamentals of democracy in the United
States in a very long time.
The term sedition is being used.
And I'm here to tell you that, yes, it is
disgusting and no, it will not work.
So let's go through it so that you understand
why these are delusional ideas that are being
put forward by Republicans that on January
6th, Mike Pence can choose instead of counting
the actual electoral votes.
For example, from Pennsylvania, Biden won.
Pennsylvania Democratic electors voted for
Joe Biden.
Beautiful.
There are Republicans claiming Mike Pence
can say, no, I'm not going to accept those
electoral votes.
I'm going to accept these alternate Republican
electoral votes from Pennsylvania.
He can't do that.
Mike Pence cannot do that.
That's not going to happen.
That's a fantasy.
Mike Pence doesn't have that power.
Mike Pence's role in this is strictly ceremonial.
But what we are going to see are objections
from the floor, from both some House Republicans
and some Senate Republicans to the counting
of the electoral votes that have been legally
cast by electors.
Right now, it's expected that there are going
to be 11 Republican senators who will claim
I object because of irregularities and they
will ask for an emergency 10 day audit to
investigate.
Now, remember, they've been investigating
two months.
Not a single court has found any of their
arguments meritorious.
Now, the really scary part is that because
of the fomenting of baseless anger by Trump
and others, there are expected to be multiple
rallies and gatherings of trumpets in D.C.
on Wednesday.
And there are fears of violence.
A variety of groups are expected to be there.
There are threats of violence, calls for an
armed and.
Which sounds a lot like that Chazz and Chop
thing that trumpets were denouncing over the
summer when it was over the George Floyd protests,
but Chaz and Chope only wanted to govern themselves.
These lunatics want to cover the entire country
by imposing an unelected president on the
United States.
We've come to expect that hypocrisy.
I won't dwell on that today.
And they're even calling.
There are even some Republicans calling for
violence.
Coocoo Congressman Louie Gohmert, for example,
said in effect, the court ruling would be
you got to go to the streets and be as violent
as Antifa and Black Lives Matter.
That's Louie Gohmert, former judge saying
that attorney Lin Wood, who's a pro Trump
lawyer that's been at the center of a lot
of this nonsense, says Mike Pence should be
executed for treason.
So many allusions and incitement to violence
going on.
And we'll see what happens on that front on
Wednesday.
But the bottom line, what happens voting wise
on Wednesday?
So here's how it will go.
Some Republicans will object to the counting
of the votes.
It will trigger a couple of hours of debate
in each chamber, Senate and House, and then
there will be a vote about whether to uphold
the objections.
Neither the House nor Senate will vote to
uphold the objections, and Joe Biden's election
will be certified.
That's what's going to happen.
So all of this weeks of planning and plotting
and threatening this will lead to a delay
of a few hours on Wednesday.
And we will cover all of it live for you.
They are attacking our basic democratic systems
and they should be held accountable.
It's unclear if these Republicans are going
to be held accountable, but this is really
the last thing we need in the middle of a
pandemic that has dramatically been mishandled,
where we have an urgent need to put someone
else in charge of managing the pandemic.
Joe Biden already has a team, already has
a task force.
They've been meeting, they've been working.
And there couldn't be there.
It would never be acceptable to attack democracy
in this way.
But this is an acutely bad time to do it.
So let me know on Twitter what you expect
to see happen on Wednesday.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.
All right, New Year, new expectations, new
membership code, use the code better 21.
Why?
Come on, guys, because we want a better 2021
than 2020.
Use the coupon code better 21.
All one word.
All lowercase numbers can't be lowercase,
but the letters can better 21 to get a major
discount off of the cost of a membership at
join Pakman dot com.
OK, so even though Donald Trump has been completely
missing from being the president for what
is now several months, he did post another
one of these bizarre videos on New Year's
Eve.
And this is a particularly deranged video.
I showed it to some mental health professionals
and said if this person were a patient and
came into the office making claims like these,
what would you think?
And everybody I showed it to in some version
or another said I would question whether the
patient is losing connection to reality.
We'd be thinking about whether medication
is appropriate now.
That's not a diagnosis of Trump.
It's a hypothetical about if Trump was on
your couch rather than on your TV making these
claims, what would you think?
So let's get right into it.
A very odd five minute speech posted to Trump's
Twitter on New Year's Eve. Trump not slurring
in this particular speech.
His voice does sound strange.
Let's get right into it.
In the face of great challenges this year,
Americans showed incredible grit, strength,
tenacity and resolve.
And together, we achieved truly historic victories
like nobody ever thought possible to defeat
the China virus.
We launched the largest mobilization since
World War Two.
We transformed our factories to build tens
of thousands of ventilators and millions and
millions of masks.
Virtually overnight.
Nobody thought it could be done.
We ignored the experts who demanded open borders,
and we shut down travel from China and Europe
to protect our citizens.
And we built the wall.
So this is Trump's completely delusional revisionist
history on covid.
We've been one of the biggest global failures
uncovered.
We failed on testing.
We are actively failing on vaccination, which
we'll get to tomorrow.
But this isn't new information.
We have the seventh highest per capita cases
in the world.
We have the 12th highest per capita death
rate in the world, excluding a couple of tiny
territories like San Marino and Andorra, if
we include them were 14th highest.
I won't bore you with more of that.
You're likely as sick of hearing about those
numbers as I am.
And then just last thing, Trump casually says
we built the wall.
No wall was built.
The promise was a wall across the entire border.
By January 20th.
There's two weeks left.
There's no wall.
Let's keep going.
We pioneered groundbreaking new therapies
and treatments and we saved millions of American
lives over and over again.
We were told it would be impossible to deliver
a vaccine by the end of the year.
All of the experts said absolutely unthinkable.
Trump is exaggerating.
It can't happen.
And we did it long before the end of the year.
They said it would take a medical miracle,
and that's exactly what it is.
Years from now, they'll be talking about it.
They'll be talking about this great, great
thing that we did with the vaccines.
A truly unprecedented, amazing medical miracle.
Normally developing a vaccine takes up to
ten years thanks to Operation Warp Speed.
We developed a vaccine in just nine months.
Now the lies there are a bit more nuanced.
No one said this is a straw man.
No one said you can't do a vaccine by the
end of the year.
And in fact, you can go back to my shows in
late April and early May.
And I showed you sober projections.
One was, I believe, from Goldman Sachs, which
I think what you want about them when it comes
to these these timelines, they've been pretty
good.
And they said we expect an emergency use vaccine
sometime in November and health care vaccinations
could start at the end of November or early
December.
That ended up being the case.
So it's not nobody was saying we'd have a
vaccine this year.
But remember that Trump promised us a hundred
million doses by the end of 2020.
That failed.
He then definitely promised us twenty million
vaccinated by the end of 2020.
We are only now getting to the first four
and a half, five million doses, first dose
given.
Remember, you need two doses.
So Operation Warp Speed has fallen about 90
percent short of what was promised.
And that's the bottom line fact.
And then here Trump really gets even more
delusional.
We've already begun a nationwide vaccination
program and we're sending the vaccine all
over the world.
The world will benefit, will benefit, and
everybody's calling to thank me.
We know of no calls from world leaders thanking
Trump zero.
We know of zero calls, but that's not.
Really, the big part to talk about, Trump
says we're sending the vaccine all over the
world, that's about five layers of lies.
First, many of the vaccines have nothing to
do with Operation Warp Speed.
It's pharmaceutical companies that are sending
the vaccine all over the world.
No to Trump turned down 100 million doses
of the Pfizer vaccine in late July.
So the 100 million doses were then sold by
Pfizer to other countries.
We're not sending them.
We turned them down.
So Pfizer sold them to somebody else.
We could have had them.
Trump said no.
And now Pfizer has figured out that other
countries want them and they're sending them
elsewhere.
So just wrong on four or five different levels.
Let's keep going.
Trump then singing his praises and grading
himself.
We will end the pandemic once and for all.
This is one of the most extraordinary scientific,
industrial and medical feats in history.
Everybody has it is that that's what they're
marketed down as.
And we can never let people forget where it
came from and how it came.
Trump continues to be obsessed with his marks,
as he calls them, says that the world has
marked this down as a major success.
Of course, we have the Pfizer Bion tech vaccine
thanks to Turkish immigrants in Germany.
The Moderna vaccine overseen by Israeli born
chief medical officer touchbacks and French
businessman CEO Stephane Bunzl, who's the
CEO of Moderna.
And we have the Oxford vaccine developed in
Oxford, England, starting to be approved.
What is Trump talking about?
Skipping ahead a little bit here.
Trump touts his great economy and then he
goes into some real whoppers about the GDP,
which we've been warning you about for a while.
Our economy is growing at the most rapid rate
ever recorded, thirty three point four percent
last quarter and much faster than the nations
of Europe.
Nobody can compete with us.
This one is just sad.
We had rapid GDP growth in the third quarter
after record GDP loss in the second quarter.
If you have 10 apples and a takeaway seven
and then give you six back and brag about
how no one's ever given you more apples than
me, I'm kind of an idiot, right?
Nobody would fall for that.
But people are falling for the equivalent
story that Donald Trump is telling.
And of course, it's similar with Europe.
Europe is seeing slower GDP growth because
they had less GDP decline to begin with, understand
it.
So it's a total farce.
And Donald Trump rapidly approaching his last
and final public appearances tonight in Georgia
in support of the two Republican candidate
candidates there.
I'll be covering it live.
I hope you'll join me on YouTube, twitch and
or Facebook.
You can stream it on all three at once if
you want, starting about eight thirty p.m.
Eastern Time tonight.
This is really something else as as we've
been covering a Joe Biden has been doing a
lot as president elect Donald Trump as president,
hasn't been doing a damn thing for months
now.
Many of his allies have abandoned him.
West Palm Beach doesn't seem to want him down
there in New York City, certainly doesn't
want him or his kids.
It's just sort of a sad denouement for Donald
Trump.
But Trump has found some unwavering support
in some elements of right wing media, including
on Newsmax and still in some places on Fox
News, the more sycophantic ones anyway.
So later we're going to do a deep dove into
a particular Fox News interview that went
comically haywire.
But I want to give you a sampling of the clips
that Donald Trump has been retweeting and
amplifying.
And the takeaway here for me is that the next
four years are going to be insane.
That's that's my takeaway.
We'll see if you come away with the same notion
FOX News was nuts during Barack Obama's presidency.
But Fox News competing with CNN, Newsmax for
the same audience is likely to lead to a sort
of one upmanship contest for who can come
up with the most wacky anti Biden conspiracy
theories and false reports.
So let's dove right in.
In the first clip retweeted by Donald Trump,
there was a panel on the show, The Five, about
Trump being admired in 2020.
And one of the five people figures out a way
to delusional, brownnose Donald Trump.
Trump loved it and retweeted it.
Take a look.
Well, see, I think President Trump, interestingly,
stands at the top because he has been an incredible
president.
He has, though, Maria.
He is someone who led one of the strongest
economies we saw pre covid.
This is a man who has gone to more Middle
East peace deals done in just one term alone.
He's gotten more than half of the all the
peace deals we have seen in our nation's history
done done in one term.
This is someone who got Mexico to step up
to the plate on things like illegal immigration.
This is someone who has brought a business
approach.
To Washington, D.C., therefore, solving problems
when people like Joe Biden, who have been
there forever, created the mess that President
Trump went to go fix.
And I also think it's remarkable because you
have the media who is vilified him, demonized
him, lied about him, and yet he still sits
atop the throne.
And Maria, I love you, but this must be a
hard segment for me.
So just to pick one thing, because there's
so much nonsense here, she said half of all
peace deals in the nation's history were done
by Donald Trump during his first term.
OK, that didn't ring true to me, so I decided
I would fact check it.
Now, some of these so-called deals Trump got
done were not even really peace deals.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
But if you go back to the Treaty of Tripoli
in 1835, there are 11 of what we would call
overtly peace deals.
And then there are way more that aren't called
peace deals, but effectively are peace deals
to some degree.
She says Trump did more peace deals in one
term than were previously done in all of American
history.
That is very much false.
But the real issue is that the deals Trump
did are really mirage's.
Trump did a deal with the UAE and Israel.
Those countries had already agreed to engage
independent of Trump, and they weren't in
what we would call a conflict to begin with,
Bahrain and Israel, same thing.
And then, of course, Trump's promise on Israeli-Palestinian
peace with Jared Kushner was going to figure
out for us silence.
No progress at all.
Another clip.
These are clips retweeted by Trump sucking
up to him.
This is from on a totally made up story fabricated
out of thin air about military ballot tampering.
Trump loves it.
He retweeted it.
While new investigations reveal military ballots
were major targets of Democrat voter fraud
in November, reports on Thursday note thousands
of military ballots were potentially tampered
with at polling stations during the general
election.
This after several witnesses came forward
during a hearing in Georgia Wednesday with
both photo and video evidence of rampant fraud.
Republican poll watchers also claim they got
locked out of the counting stations when it
came to look time to look over military ballots,
which typically lean red.
So that's absolutely nuts.
Not a single court has found any merit to
any of the claims you just heard.
Trump doesn't care.
He loves it.
He tweets it.
Next clip also from on, which presents a battle
for the White House battle.
The election's over, Biden won, Trump lost,
doesn't matter, Trump loves it.
This one is made even funnier because the
anchor is struggling to deliver the scripted
agit trash like she's she's struggling to
even read this nonsense off of the prompter.
The battle continues for the White House as
President Trump and his legal team continue
to reveal and investigate the irregularities
of the 2012 election.
President Trump has several avenues to secure
his second term.
Primarily, the state legislatures have the
constitutional authority and responsibility
to select the correct electors for their respective
states.
Seven states had both sets of electors vote
on December 14th.
Pennsylvania, Georgia, Michigan, Wisconsin,
Arizona, Nevada and New Mexico all had Republican
electors cast their votes as well as the Democrat
electors.
Currently, all seven of the state secretaries
of state have sent the Democrat electors to
be counted.
The state legislatures have the constitutional
responsibility to ensure that the electors
sent from their state are correct.
So that's a complete fantasy.
None of that is going on.
And then one more here may be the nuttiest
one and only one reporter named Pearson Sharp
stands in front of a blackboard reminiscent
of Glenn Beck's old conspiracy show, a bunch
of stuff written in chalk outlining a completely
farcical understanding of how elections work.
This is a five minute clip.
I'm not going to torture you like that.
I'll just play 40 seconds for you to give
you a sense of it.
The so-called election results on November
3rd are puzzling to a lot of people, at least.
Seventy five million, but probably a lot more.
That's because up until that point, all signs
were that President Trump was set to win a
historic victory over Joe Biden.
And many still believe that's exactly what
happened.
Even if the alleged vote counts, tell a different
story.
Despite what the mainstream media has declared,
President Trump was projected to win because
he had ushered in an unprecedented era of
prosperity for Americans from all walks of
life.
At the start of twenty twenty before the Chinese
pandemic and Democratic governors devastated
our nation.
American optimism about the economy was at
an all time high.
That guy has never seen a point he will actually
make, just droning on and on with circumstantial
conjecture.
But his point is Trump won and Trump liked
it.
So Trump retweeted that video.
These are the things where if you even see
a reputable reporter re tweet this, you say,
wow, that's a concern.
The president of the United States is retweeting
this stuff.
We'll have more coverage of this on our Instagram
page.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show and follow me on Instagram for
pictures from my vacation warning.
They are very boring.
I'm David Pakman on Instagram, T